NAMOR
My ancestors would often say...
...only the most broken people,
can be great leaders.
[Chanting]
CROWD
RYAN COOGLER
Introducing Namor was really
an opportunity to introduce another
sovereign ruler of a group of people.
He shows up representing Talokan.
SHURI
He's coming for the surface world.
NATE MOORE
In Marvel publishing,
Namor was one of the
first Super Heroes, frankly.
M'BAKU
They called him, K'uk'ulkan.
The Feather Serpent God.
TENOCH HUERTA MEJÍA
Namor loves his people
and he's gonna protect them,
because to be a ruler
you have to serve the people.
TaloKan has a deep meaning for me.
It's part of my personal heritage
as a Mexican, as an inhabitant
of Mesoamerica.
Finally, I could find a more powerful
representation of my culture,
with dignity and respect.
LETITIA WRIGHT
I cannot wait for everyone to see Talokan.
I'm excited about how we're gonna
see the world come alive.
Both nations want the same
thing, which is to preserve
and to protect their people, but they're
willing to go about it different ways.
NAMOR
I need to know if Wakanda
is an ally or an enemy.
ANGELA BASSETT
Namor is very much concerned
with what he needs
and what he wants.
This delicate dance
between the two of them,
I get chills just thinking about it.
RAMONDA
Who are you?
♪♪
NAMOR
My enemies call me Namor.